yeah you're not minutes to boil water
for straight Iced Out man for my Bible a
Capcom you know how we get down camera
with babies my sock 975 listen today's
hottest music poop night kev and you
already know man i got one of the
hottest artists on the planet right now
what up big dog without minister bar for
lanka Vegas man look good right man for
sure it's your first time in vegas yeah
I look good man most definitely it's
gonna be crazy tonight ladies love you
out here fam Shh I love don't even know
and I gotta admit you man I was like I
was kind of I didn't get the flock of
movement for a while right and then my
homie Rams this is like he's he loves
you man he liked loved your music shop
around we rode out to phoenix Flockaveli
on the whole time and I got I got I got
to my mom's house and I wanted to punch
somebody man I was like get it is that
it's that you know that get hype music
you don't have said enjoy yourselves
music yes yes anyway man so uh first
time in Vegas a lot of rumors going
you're a controversial do man oh man
that crazy it is crazy every time I go
to worldstar hiphop flock is doing
something or some something's going on
media takeout or something like is it
crazy like just so many rumors always
going around about you man no it's crazy
I'll be watching waka flocka's a whole
new person our government why can't I
can never be Waka Flocka that's just
like her it's like a by my chocolates my
nine-to-five you know yeah yeah it's
Waka Flocka gave me is two different
people so it's kind of a pretty worried
is real but I can't get stuck in their
lifestyle can't bring my right life to
my personal life so rumors rooms it's
all good man just boost the show price
most yeah always always always I guess
people talking about you man and we was
just kind of talking off the air me and
Jay nice a lot of people thought you
might have gotten locked up or yeah I
know how to work your house got raided
or something like that yeah never went
to Malta grounds you know like I pulled
over a ticket right ain't go cop
autograph ran outside games lower level
no that's what happened hello
outside now of course first time in
Vegas man for everybody coming to the
show tonight what can they expect what
what can they expect yeah what can they
expect oh man hey going man expect the
unexpected bit I'm gonna cry I'm in
Vegas that's all I gotta say uofa so
it's going down Wow going down going
down tonight crown hotel tonight is
going down and I wanted to ask you man I
was I saw your boy Gucci and yourself
you're thinking about maybe doing some
sort of reality show yeah that's one
that's on the hall table it's on the
table yeah it'd be very entertaining
away it'll be entertainment it seems
like you be I got a very funny guy to
watch on TV like you seems like your
life is like just TV ready man oh I love
all their hope you think I make it make
sense cuz when I a when they put them
cameras up on us I don't tell them we
smiled and I'll tell what we go vydor I
was something what did you think of a
Gucci getting that ice cream cone tatted
on his face man like I just hey we
should wear those I don't tell what they
call do it are you gonna get the fozzie
bear tattoo on the face did I know okay
i touch your muffin it's good man good
you know I'm saying you gotta keep it
pretty for the ladies you feel me
therefore it's okay we get we
pre-recorded right now anyway there's a
la flaca values out you got the smash
record no hands ya got no hands I just
look like Bilbo Tottenham all hip-hop
song um I got my album coming up came
out downloaded on iTunes I got a label
brick squad monopoly hey can I can I be
like a honorary member of brick squad
tonight I mean can I get down man yeah
okay for sure why not I'm just I'm just
trying to get some of the leftover
groupies you feeling scopus I don't know
I only believe in groupies I call them
women that's just in love which and I
must say I respect you [__] cuz cuz
most people someone throws something on
stage at a show they'll let security
handle it flying said hell naw so don't
know that mean I'm coming into the crowd
for your please no some dope do pain
like a pitch on me like not telling a
person meet me I already got the whole
outlook on me
and cause a monster he's bringing
gangbang into the area and then when I
come there could be the total opposite
so now now when I see a person I just
always seems like oh hey man I'm before
I met judges thought so much about you
now yeah he's raised you think people
kind of kind of already make their mind
up about you before they meet you you
know you know you know kinda our live by
if you don't know me I don't I don't
expect you to respect me all understand
me cuz you don't know me and I ain't
finna fault you for that anybody talk
done I'll never get mad at that's all I
could say hey so calm because the man
don't know me he just gonna information
stuff he read about right so he meet me
as a whole total different thing how did
you fall into the into the rapping thing
man cause I know you kind of like openly
it made it like I you know the lyrics
and all that stuff I ain't even trippin
always let's get this money like how did
you come into coming to the rap game
anyway then one damn one anyway I was
all honestly though oh I was downs like
my last to diagnose you know I go he
trying to go for the quick flips he
won't be broken um alright yeah hey
stuff got messed up I end up losing all
the money teen tylenol and at the time I
like Toussaint like played 4 songs go
soja may always do it that stories on
haven't made of my life really yeah i
probably made a mixed in about a week at
first mix it cuz lumia shoot me all they
do is on engines pop that's that's what
something this month up to it pops
months after that's what's going on man
so of course hopefully the reality show
comes to fruition out to be fresh and
are you already working on the next
album yo right now it's called triple F
life friends fans and family I'm working
on it that's big what's it got friends
fans and family trouble of life I
thought Flockaveli was like one of them
illus titles like a valley hard home bit
imma be marvellous a no no definitely an
end for real though your album is it's
like man it's that music like if I want
to go work out bang bang everybody don't
we gangster I'll get a lot of in being
like sports players period they always
email be tellin LMAO album man we
working out that there are no start
though before the games and everything
most definitely my do while we
appreciate you stopping through tonight
it's going down crown nightclub Waka
Flocka in the building and uh man ladies
come correct cuz what this is Vegas
using are you single right
crying I'm single what do you look for
in the ladies tonight for when they come
to crown what are you what are you
looking for I look for whatever attract
me so itchy you don't just I don't have
no I don't have no taste no race Pacific
whatever attract me that's with
something pink purple brown I don't care
anything if the track me on with it I'm
in the club may cry on the night I'm
taking pitches I'm going in we busting
bottle we having fun today I wanted to
ask you to a one more question um it's
funny the other day my friend was
playing at Shea you seen the short bus
shorty videos yeah what do you think
about stuff like that people kind of
like um you know mock mock what you do
Alma's entertainment it's photos funny
to me honestly okay person I guys I
thought it was hilarious cuz I you know
yeah then today I met the people that
made it was funny right it was fighting
and it was some looking so how can you
get mad at some little kids just and it
helps it helps promote you know yeah
millions and millions of hits on YouTube
is like 17 if they want it done but none
are you mad at that man hey can't get
mad at the show but show di walk we
gonna see you tonight man crown
nightclub thank you for your time sir I
rulers going down man hot 97 five